hey this is presh talwalkar
this problem was part of a written
interview test for amazon in india
a drawer contains 12 identical black
socks and 12 identical white socks
if you pick two socks at random what is
the probability of getting a matching
pair
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
many people think when you pick two
socks they will either match or they
will not match
since the number of black and white
socks are equal
the probability of matching should be
fifty percent
but this tempting answer is wrong
the probability of making a pair is
actually slightly less than fifty
percent
let's calculate and figure out why
there are 12 white socks and 12 black
socks
by symmetry the probability of picking a
black pair of socks equals the
probability of picking a white pair of
socks
so let's calculate the probability of
picking a black pair of socks
there is a 12 over 24 chance the first
sock is black
this is because there are 12 black socks
out of 24 socks total
12 over 24 simplifies to be one half
now what's the chance of picking a black
sock on the second draw
for the second sock the chance will be
11 out of 23
because there are 11 black socks
remaining out of a total of 23 socks
remaining asymmetry is because we are
sampling without replacement
so what does this all mean
it means the probability of picking a
black pair
is one half
times 11 over 23
this will also be the probability of
picking a white pair by symmetry
so we can put this all together to get
the odds of picking a pair of matching
socks
the probability of picking a matching
pair will equal the probability of
picking a black pair plus the
probability of picking a white pair
each of these is equal to one-half times
11 over 23
and therefore the probability of picking
a pair of matching socks will be 11 over
23 which is approximately
47.8 percent
this is slightly less than one half
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
mindyourdecisions
if you like this video you can support
me on patreon
and you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description you can
also follow me on social media either at
mind your decisions or at preshtalwalkar
depending on the site